there was a uh a black officer who
wanted to start an organization an
internal organization
where only black people and then he
would have preferred only black gay
people could come to a meeting right so
in other words on government property
with inside langley
you had to be black and you had to be
gay in order to come to those meetings
now i don't even know how many people
would fit the bill there maybe like
seven or eight so i'm not sure what
you've done at that meeting but
nevertheless uh the point is there was
this very clearly discriminatory uh
request by an officer who should have
known better uh but he made the request
and the office of general counsel i had
to come in and say no that is wildly
inappropriate we're not doing that and
he was actually livid he was livid uh
that he had to be told no and to be
reminded of the law
so that kind of woke-ism stuff matched
with i think some of the the pr stuff
you see coming out of the cia these days
you may recall that young woman in the
twitter video saying
culture and you know folks who are a
little bit older who came through i
think the era frankly of the 90s uh such
as yourself and myself that the gen xers
were like look we don't care who you are
just coming to do the work
we want to treat everybody with with uh
you know respect and equal opportunity
but it's now like you now have to
believe what i do
and if you don't you're a bigot or a
racist or homophobe etc and that's new
and that's only been in the past for
five to ten years really started under
the obama years
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former cia officer and host of the new
podcast the president's daily brief
brian dean wright welcome back to the
reuben report pleasure as always my
friend
brian you've been on a couple times i i
know you a bit outside of the show um i
did not know you were the president is
there something i've been missing here
well it was i started first with a local
group of dog owners as the president of
that club and i've moved all the way to
the white house in my mind and it's
great just me and joe and we're working
on a hunter's laptop it's going to be a
all fixed up don't you worry about that
the president's daily brief that's the
name of the show you have a real
pedigree in the cia that i want to talk
about for people that have not seen some
of your other appearances on my show i
want to recap some of that stuff but
let's just just off the name of the of
the new show the president's daily brief
now i'm not a big believer in this guy
something does not seem right with this
guy i'm starting to think this guy may
not be in charge is this your way of
kind of getting in and in case something
happens saying hey i'm here i've got the
title of the show etc uh i wasn't
thinking about that but now that you
mention it yes and i'm ready to serve uh
because let's be honest kamala's number
two and that's also a hot mess
and then we got pelosi uh we all know
where that's going so yeah it's me
i'm ready
it's you it's you all right for for
people that that don't know you we'll
link to the original interview below if
they want the full the full recap but
can you just give me a little of the
brian dean right 101 a little bit of
your history in the cia and then also we
have a sort of similar political path
that we should get into a bit as well
yeah so i
began my career with the cia just after
the 9 11 attacks it was uh october of
2001.
you know we we were all panicked uh as
we all started our young careers as you
know folks who loved this country we had
just been hit in the face nobody quite
knew exactly who when and and you know
where abroad that we might be hit from
next so that really kicked off my career
at the agency and i was there for a good
number of years focused on weapons of
mass destruction and counterterrorism as
most of us did
focused a little bit in asia can't get
in particulars and then also in africa
and it was an amazing career and i had a
great great time doing it and been
fortunate to actually teach the next
cadre or next generation of officers as
well so i've had a really really fun
career
and then towards the very end got
introduced to a few different people to
include you and had a great opportunity
that was just by lucky happenstance to
start talking about different issues in
the world particularly national security
and here we are with a podcast and i'm
really excited
how tough is it
to make that transition because cia you
gotta be somebody that can't drop all
the secrets all the time and then next
thing you know you're talking on camera
doing a podcast yeah uh how do you blend
those two things spend uh 20 years
avoiding cameras and attention and now
here i am
uh
it's an odd transition you know i think
if you talk to anybody who has really
been a true operator they they
understand the importance of being
anonymous you know unlike let's say
james bond or you know those characters
the idea is that you go into somewhere
and start blowing stuff up
the idea is you go in you're very quiet
you're discreet you do what you need to
do and then you leave and actually no
one ever knows so if you're pulling out
a gun or you're tossing a bomb like
something's gone pretty wrong right
so uh but the the idea of then sitting
in front of a camera and engaging people
yes was absolutely odd but i will tell
you
that in in many ways that the job has a
lot of
parallels in that
if you do it well and if you do it right
and and with all
truly i think you're one of them you you
really can capture people's hearts and
minds and you can move people and i
think with intelligence you can do that
with your listeners or your your viewers
uh you know if you're briefing the
president right so the president's daily
brief is an actual brief given to the
president united states every morning by
our spies and analysts and you can
capture the president's attention not
only with what's happening in the world
uh but how do we solve the problems and
and why he or she should care about
those problems so uh i i think in that
sense there are some parallels and i'm
really excited to bring that kind of
background to this podcast and bring
listeners that same
focus that same piece of critical
information every morning so i actually
want to talk about the real president's
brief that you just
mentioned as well as whether you think
joe is actually reading it or whether
they even bother handing it to him or
even if they're printing it at this
point but putting that aside for a
second yeah it struck me as you were
saying that that if if five years ago
and i had you on probably maybe three or
four years ago but if let's say five or
even seven years ago i had had a former
cia officer on my feeling about the cia
as an institution
would be very different than it is right
now and i think a lot of people feel
that and it's not with any great
pleasure i say that i suspect for you
with a lot of displeasure can you talk
about what has sort of happened to the
agencies like we see this woke thing
infecting absolutely everything i mean
the cia the fbi the military they're
tweeting about woke stuff more than
seemingly doing whatever it is that they
are supposed to do even if we're not
supposed to know all that stuff right
so man i'll tell you that there are two
things that i think folks should really
be focusing on the first is the the
weaponization of the intelligence
community you know we knew back in may
of 2017 james comey the fbi director at
the time acknowledged that he had leaked
uh sensitive classified information to a
cutout to the new york times with the
only goal
of basically hammering
donald trump getting a new special
counsel uh to investigate the the russia
collusion allegations now comey knew
back then and unfortunately we were only
learning in the last number of years
that that was garbage right so we saw
that in the fbi we later saw it with a
guy named kevin kleinsmith who was this
very senior fbi official who falsified
evidence to a court to get surveillance
or continue surveillance on carter page
so i think that had you told me that
seven years ago that that was in the
realm of possible i would have to be
honest with you i would like you out of
the room because what i knew to be true
is that we had people who were committed
to the rule of law whether it be the fbi
or the cia we were committed to our
oaths to be non-political uh apolitical
certainly when we walked through those
front doors and we were focused on
mission
but that has been completely and utterly
annihilated that is to say my belief
that the intelligence community and the
fbi are
not political they are we have proof we
have evidence it's it's painful uh
because the very moment that we are
facing this massive challenge with china
this huge issue with russia
we actually need a really good healthy
functional intelligence community and
law enforcement community and on the
federal level we just we don't have it i
can't tell you or the folks watching
that they've got the kind of government
that they deserve because i don't think
that they do
do you know when
that started there because now we're
seeing it more obviously but it didn't
just start because they started tweeting
about this stuff six months ago
obviously
yeah
well i'll tell you i think candidly of
politics aside i think during the obama
years you started seeing a lot of people
misunderstanding that
they were there to be of service to
their country and instead those agencies
and ultimately their countries was to be
of service to them i mean jack kennedy
said it very famously many decades ago
that started to change i think
culturally
in the obama years because it was really
about me was about the self you know my
truth and celebrating that
and so we went i think from you know the
early 2000s when you know people were
saying very clearly look it doesn't
matter if you're gay or straight or
christian or muslim or black and white
just come in and be of service leave
your politics at the door
so that was i think where most of us
would be is to say yeah get the equal
opportunity that's focused on mission
and now it's become instead of mission
or really at the same level of mission
tell me what you're passionate about
what your interests are like tell me
your story and your truth uh stuff
that's not mission critical but it's
being treated as such and i can tell you
a couple of amazing stories on the
inside of the agency about how this the
racial world piece is really detrimental
we're playing a profoundly detrimental
role in mission criticalness
give me one of those
all right so there was an integration
yeah a lot of them unfortunately there
was a
black officer who wanted to start an
organization an internal organization
where only black people and then he
would have preferred only black gay
people could come to a meeting right so
in other words on government property
with inside langley you had to be black
and you had to be gay in order to come
to those meetings now i don't even know
how many people would have fit the bill
there maybe like seven or eight so i'm
not sure what you've done at that
meeting but nevertheless uh the point is
there was this very clearly
discriminatory
requests by an officer who should have
known better but he made the request and
the office of general counsel had to
come in and say no that is wildly
inappropriate we're not doing that and
he was actually livid
he was livid
that he had to be told no and to be
reminded of the law
so that kind of vocalism stuff matched
with i think some of the the pr stuff
you see coming out of the cia these days
you may recall that young woman in the
twitter video saying that she was a
what was
little bit older who came through i
think the era frankly of the 90s uh such
as yourself and myself that the gen xers
were like look we don't care who we are
just coming to do the work uh we want to
treat everybody with with uh you know
respect and equal opportunity but it's
now like you now have to believe what i
do
and if you don't you're a bigot or a
racist or homophobe etc and that's new
and that's only been in the past for
five to ten years really started under
the obama years are you shocked that the
institutions didn't have better defenses
against this i've asked this to many
guests from many different disciplines
usually at the education level that
you'd think that some of the stem
subjects would have had better defenses
people were like oh yeah of course you
know lesbian dance theory was going to
go down but you know math perhaps or
biology that should have been okay but
now we're seeing it across there are you
surprised that our our actual i mean
these are our most highest elite
security services now are going down
that they did not have some fail safe in
there
look am i surprised yeah i think most
people in this country right now are not
just surprised but shocked right i think
most people want to be reasonable and
want to be compassionate about you know
welcoming different people into their
families and to their communities
but we're we're seeing that
go well beyond any degree of reason
and so i think the cia you're seeing a
reflection of what people are
experiencing outside of langley in their
own families in their own communities
they're feeling that pressure to sort of
conform
and then they're being told from the top
down from the president's office him or
herself like you have to do this and
they're like well i'm not going to be
fired so i guess i have to you know go
along with it and and that's what i
think you're seeing even the very very
smart very very critical thinking people
are starting to fall into this trap
because they they're going to lose their
job if they don't when you saw the
51 i believe it was
former
intelligence officers
who all said that the hunter biden
laptop was russian misinformation or
disinformation they all said it without
having seen it okay
when you saw that so let's go back
before it's been debunked but when it
originally came out i'm talking during
the election when they all came out and
said that conveniently enough right
before the election
what was your take then
compared to now
both then and now my reaction was the
same there is absolutely no way to know
unless you do a forensic analysis of
whether or not that laptop a belonged to
hunter biden and b if there was any
additional information added that would
be thus disinformation or propaganda or
part of some sort of covert action op by
the russians the chinese whoever it
might be
so to immediately come out and just
dismiss it
was absurd and what it showed me was
that those people on that list were
partisans they were they were using the
the stink as it were of working at the
cia being an intelligence officer to you
know go out to the american people with
some degree of gravitas like they're
sort of mini james bond or whoever it
might be and so you're going to take
them seriously and so they abused
their professional histories to make
this partisan point and so again we we
saw this by the way not just with the
the hunter biden laptop we saw this with
the steele dossier that that's perhaps
even more agreed just years prior to
that when i i think you could say
where's the point where we really
started seeing this publicly you had a
whole bunch of intelligence officials
who damn well know better that when you
get information which is what was inside
the steele dossier which is russia right
that you have to tr you know tread very
very cautiously around russian intel
because of the likelihood that it has
been fed in this case to steal the the
british spy
so when you had people saying oh that
this deal dossier is true it's got to be
true that's why i was like all right
this
this whole thing has been cooked the
this is absolutely members of the ic
wanting to be part of the hillary
clinton administration or the joe biden
administration now who are trying to
gain favor and they're using their
backgrounds to do so and it's just
infuriating because ultimately what
happens and what has happened is the
american people lose faith in the
intelligence community
they lose faith in the law enforcement
community and rightfully so and so when
that happens you got a whole bunch of
people with lots of profound powers who
don't actually have the support of the
american people they start acting
basically with impunity because they can
it just countries start falling apart
when this stuff happens and that's the
part that that i'm so profoundly afraid
right so i try not to be a crazy
alarmist on this show try maybe i fail
at it but i try not to be but it seems
to me that's kind of where we're at
because when the 51
intelligence
officers in in essence former
propagandist propagandists i was trying
to be nice thank you for cleaning that
up for me yeah you don't have when those
51 propagandists were exposed as such
meaning the new york times finally a
year and a half later everyone knows
this now a month and a half ago or so
finally he said yeah yeah the laptop was
real by the way did anyone get called
into an office did anyone get fired from
a consulting gig they got did anyone get
fired from the lobbying firm or anything
i suspect not and that goes to your
point about the trust it's like
i think they sort of feel i can get away
with anything because
they can get away with anything
yeah
well and there was a report out some
time back that the joe biden
administration has actually encouraged
and allowed this junk
intel to go out about ukraine i mean
all because he wants to try to encourage
the american people to embrace a greater
involvement in the war so you are having
this this intelligence fiasco after
fiasco and at some level i think a
reasonable person says i've had enough
whenever you say american intelligence
assesses i'm i'm not going to believe it
and i can't tell those people right now
particularly with the current leadership
that they're wrong
and that's that's really sad for a guy
who spent most of his life in the world
of intelligence let's shift that a
little bit to what you just mentioned
there so so this russia ukraine
situation i actually have not covered it
a ton on the show i i was very honest
with my audience from the beginning i
was kind of like
this whole thing
reads very weird to me
the whole setup
the biden laptop piece of it
suddenly we all got to hate russia i'm
not defending russia you can't just
invade a sovereign nation but it just
there it just felt like so much
propaganda that i've i've bounced around
it a little bit and i've talked about
the after effects meaning inflation and
gas and things like that and i've tried
to talk about what we should do perhaps
and shouldn't do but i'm not doing the
daily thing with russia and ukraine how
are you able to assess information
properly because i think people are just
you know you put the ukrainian flag in
your twitter avatar everybody else is an
evil nazi that's it i suspect it's not
quite that simple
oh dear no uh so you know you know that
you're caught in hysteria when and this
is true
both of the major marathons in this
country have banned runners from ukraine
or russia i should say russia or uh
bella russia from running right right so
we're banning marathons not ukraine
because of their national identity right
and we're pouring out you know we're
renaming chicken kiev and it's chicken
keef it's a stop all right it's we are
this is hysteria defined
so i i think that it's important for
people like me
to speak to these issues around war and
peace and including in ukraine knowing
that there is a fog of war issue so when
i talk about ukraine or any other places
around the world i'm going to be very
careful to make sure that i have medium
or high degree of confidence in what i'm
sharing with people now this issue of
confidence is one that is very familiar
to anybody who's worked in the
intelligence community
you don't put out to policymakers or the
public low confidence information low
confidence information means you haven't
vetted it or the person right you
haven't compared that report that that
spy is giving you to maybe you've
captured an email or a phone call or
you've gotten other spies who are
confirming the same same information so
in other words there's this issue of
confidence you want to give policymakers
medium to high degree of confidence in
your assessments i do that the same
to have that same focus in spirit when i
talk about the things on the president's
daily brief the podcast and that's what
the intelligence community should be
doing right now on the issues of ukraine
and others but that's not what's
happening again this report that came
out not too terribly long ago that
confirmed the biden administration is
putting out low confidence intel
gossip rumors to the american press
about what's happening
in the ukraine
example
the story that russia was going to
utilize uh chemical or biological
weaponry uh that story came out in in
february into march there was actually
no intelligence that said that that
would happen now it it could still in
the future or perhaps as we're speaking
it just has but the point is at the
moment when they gave that story to the
american people to the world it wasn't
true so when you start doing that when
you start just pumping out
low confidence information information
that's probably just gossip and rumors
you do this horrible thing of
undermining confidence in the
intelligence community and oh by the way
dave we did this before do you remember
in the run-up in the war of uh iraq we
started that war because of weapons of
mass destruction that was the story that
was sold to people we had low confidence
that that was true by the way it was
based on one guy the operation was
curveball and curveball was a big old
liar and it was responsibility and
intelligence community to vet that
person their information to say nope
that was a lie didn't colin powell say
there was a rod i thought colin powell
went in front of congress and said he
saw a rod or something yeah yeah sure
well i'm sure they all saw lots of
things after they were they were wrong
namely their retirements yeah uh but the
the issue is so now the intelligence
community when i was at the cia we all
were burned by that case and we said to
each other particularly the analysts
never again never again are we going to
be allowed to pump out low competence
low confidence garbage intel into the
world because we're going to get
ourselves in trouble again we're going
to cause trillion dollar wars with
hundreds of thousands of people dead
like in iraq or thousands and thousands
of our soldiers and airmen and the rest
who come home without arms and legs and
their minds are broken like that's the
legacy of putting out garbage intel and
joe biden is doing it again in the
ukraine what do you make of what i would
argue is the like
absolutely extraordinary level of
incompetence of this administration when
it comes to the messaging so for example
when just a couple weeks ago there was
suddenly this rumor that they were going
to use russia was going to use chemical
weapons i did not bother saying a word
about it because it just felt
nonsensical to me because why wouldn't
you in a war of propaganda just be like
yeah the other guy is going to use
chemical weapons that's a pretty good
move
but then
joe biden was asked a question about
chemical weapons and he said if he uses
him we'll respond in kind now i don't
think he has the greatest understanding
of what he's saying on any given moment
especially when it's completely off
prompter but that everything they say we
did an incredible uh compilation on my
show a couple weeks ago of the mixed
messaging related to sanctions sanctions
will stop them sanctions do nothing
sanctions do a little sanctions do a lot
everybody from the president to saki to
kamala to the whole crew just saying
every version of everything
yeah
well you were highlighting the
inconsistencies the american people see
the inconsistencies and that's why at
this present moment joe biden's approval
numbers uh are about those of a really
bad case of hemorrhoids and so it makes
sense the american people are they see
through it we all see through it
and it ultimately beyond the political
ramifications for the rest of this year
for instance in the run-up to the
midterm elections it also has profound
implications in terms of our
relationships with people abroad
because for instance when we start
sharing bits and pieces of intelligence
is that really true and we're asking
these countries to do things on our
behalf because of this intelligence
right so that's the cost from our
national security perspective
when they're putting out bogus
information or they're putting out stuff
that's even inconsistent with their own
values so if joe biden says that we're
going to respond in kind with chemical
weaponry are they going to pause and say
well
we don't want to hitch our nation's
wagon to this country america right now
because it's being led by a crazy person
who obviously is mentally incapacitated
to some degree and clearly is not able
to make good decisions or can't even put
out the right words to do so so
there's there's pretty serious national
security ramifications to his mumblings
and and we all see it it's reflected in
the approval numbers but i guarantee you
when capitals around the world right now
they see it too
how do we reverse
some of this stuff because okay we could
all say all right the errors always seem
to be in the democrats favor or the
leaks are always to the new york times
in the favor of the democrats et cetera
et cetera but this isn't just okay elect
more republicans and you're going to
save the intelligence services right i
mean what is the
solution well you know i mentioned jack
kennedy earlier he has a pretty famous
quote that i i love and i embrace and
it's uh you know when we seek out
solutions let us not seek the democratic
answer the republican answer but the
right answer
and i think that most reasonable people
in this country understand that that's
really how you should govern uh and
that's how you should lead your own
families not necessarily in terms of
your politics but you look for the right
way to do things based on you know
reasoned and critical thinking
so the issue then is at this moment in
time
do we have two parties or two movements
or another party that we're not
considering beyond the democrats
republicans who are committed to
critical thinking to to reason or is one
of them just so wildly off the mark that
we just have to say look for right now
those people are too crazy and that for
me
uh that decision was very obvious about
a year ago i left the democrat party i
became a republican not because of any
you know profound affection or affinity
for republicanism in general although
i've always been a conservative but the
point is
we actually have people on the left
right now the democrat party which i've
been a part of for a long time was my
family who are saying critical
thinking's bad
right reason is bad why because those
are things that white people do and
white is bad
that's not hyperbole by the way they're
saying this you know this you've spoken
about this eloquently
so if that's part of the
the answer that people are when they
have to go to the the ballot box and
they're saying okay do i wanna
do i wanna elected people who don't
think that reason or critical
thinking is a good thing in fact it's a
bad thing because it's white like no it
doesn't even matter what the rest of
their solutions are those people are
crazy
and i'm not going to to to vote for them
now you very again eloquently talk about
that the left is
you know mentally bonkers they're
mentally ill and that's true the party
is full of these folks and because they
are so full of these sort of panicked
hysterical ways of thinking that they're
not responsible enough to govern there
are some democrats still who are
reasonable but they choose to be quiet
right some of the blue dogs for instance
they have chosen to just be quiet to go
along to get along
and that's
that's just not enough right i mean
there aren't enough of them and they
certainly aren't speaking up to say yep
all right they're crazy elements but i'm
going to give them a shot because those
people are not in leadership and they
never will be so that's exactly why i
said at the beginning that we've had
similar political evolutions because you
were a democrat most of your life and
you've probably heard me say it but my
new line that i've been saying for about
a year and a half now is you don't have
to be a republican but you cannot be a
democrat that that seems like the honest
assessment it does not mean that these
guys are right and they screw up an
awful lot of stuff
yeah but as aoc said you don't have to
be factually right you have to be
morally correct that is that is some
dangerous
dangerous stuff
yeah well it's reflective of her
political movement which is not
liberalism it's it's marxism and she's
very clear although she hides it on
occasion or dresses it up in tick-tock
dance videos to make people think that
it's cute and fun but you are absolutely
right you have called this out
consistently and folks watching know
that that is absolutely uh the truth uh
because we have eyes and ears and we
listen to people on the left right now
um you know the the video that went
around some time back of uh you know i
think it was dennis prager who who went
on the bill mayor show a number of years
ago and was talking about this idea of
sort of the trans uh movement and that
right now you know a bunch of people are
saying that men can menstruate and what
was so interesting uh is of course the
bill mayer and others were laughing at
him at the absurdity that anybody would
propose such a thing but it was also
that the audience the audience was
laughing at uh the suggestion that men
could menstruate they all thought it was
just this absurd thing these crazy
right-wing people are saying but it
turns out he was right both then and now
and other people are making this
argument look look
not only are you telling us that we
can't think or we can't think for
ourselves or think can't think
critically or with reason but now you're
actually telling us to abandon basic
biology basic facts and so the question
is why why are you having us do this
because this is crazy and so politically
speaking you're going to start losing a
lot of people who otherwise identify as
you know democrats or you know moderate
democrats even some progressives that
i've talked to i'm sure you have as well
they're like
okay i don't know where this is going uh
where it came from but this is really
weird um they want to be embracing
all kinds of different people and they
want to create a lovely opportunity for
folks to excel in life
but this stuff of of you know the magic
closet where teachers right now are
telling you know
trans kids that they can go into the
secret closet with the teacher and
swap out their clothes but don't tell
mom and dad i mean come on that's
ridiculous that kind of stuff that's
creepy it is grooming behavior and it's
wildly inappropriate yeah and people are
more upset with the label grooming than
actually what's going on in the freaking
secret closet and to your point about
dennis prager that was probably a year
and a half ago and uh you know just in
the last couple weeks we confirmed a
supreme court justice who isn't a
biologist so she has no freaking clue
what the difference between a male and a
female is but but okay so let's let's if
if someone's listing this and they're
like all right i won't vote for
democrats at least for now i'll vote for
republicans so now we get all the
republicans in we get the red wave that
that i pray will happen because we need
it at least for now
what will they do
that will fix the intelligence agencies
i mean what really is that we just
cleaning house firing you know you hear
some people just fire everybody or close
i mean i hear people talking about just
close them all just get rid of everybody
yeah well look i think all options have
to be on the table and i think that you
have to understand that within the
department of defense the fbi the cia
and the nsa there is a history of doing
a pretty profound
investigation as it were panels on the
the house intelligence select committees
there was a church committee back in the
1970s when there were all kinds of
horrible things the intelligence
community the cia was doing they had
these conversations where they said look
you guys are out of control and here's
what we need to do to fix it so in other
words let's acknowledge there's a
problem
and then let's talk about how we fix the
problem and i think that that's where
you need to start and i think
republicans would be very very wise in
both the house and the senate to have
those series of investigative
conversations those panels those
committee conversations and probably
many months long where you just start
you know airing some dirty laundry
inside the intel community some of the
bad things that they would probably
otherwise
folks want you know they don't want us
to know about put it out there and let's
have uh you know some solutions based on
how bad the rod is this is happening by
the way in the military that they're
becoming super woke as well i i've had
the great fortune of working with folks
in the military for a good number of
years they see it too i've seen it too
there so this is broad and we need to
have some really good oversight diving
into this issue it's not just the woke
stuff it's how did it start who embraces
it moving those people who aren't
focused on mission and then you know
rising other individuals up into
positions of authority and influence who
i don't care if they're republican or
democrat conservative or liberal
whatever
they have a an exclusive understanding
of mission right a faithful commitment
to law and order and that they take an
oath and they understand what that means
and that is to be of service to the
american people and to the mission and
they leave politics behind that's what
has to be reinstalled into the
intelligence community fbi the cia nsa
and also our military how do you do that
you got to remove some people
unquestionably that's going to happen
do you look at folding you know the fbi
i'm open not to you know collapsing the
entirety of it but if you want to shift
the mission
different parts of the national security
division for instance other places let's
talk about it i don't know what the
solution is but we need dramatic and
complete reform
what i always think sits behind a
conversation like this and i've had this
type of conversation with you before and
i've had it with other people and you've
obviously had it with tons and tons of
other people is like are you afraid to
talk about some of this stuff like don't
they put the drink you know the drop in
the drink when you're looking the wrong
way or or the litany of weird things or
drop information on you or smear you or
go to the new york times and lie i mean
the litany of things that they can do to
anybody in a time especially when it's
fueled by algorithms and and a media
that's not an honest arbiter of truth i
mean you're saying some pretty
you know it's it's some scary stuff that
obviously some powerful people will not
be thrilled to hear
yeah
well not to be cliched about this but if
you remember the founding in this
country when someone asked i believe it
was benjamin franklin what kind of
government that he and the rest of the
founding fathers and mothers gave us his
response was a republic if you can keep
it right so explicit in that response
from the very foundation of our
government is you have to get in there
roll up your sleeves and get dirty
and unfortunately that getting dirty
sometimes can be somebody solely in your
reputation at worst or doing you
physical harm uh i should say best and
doing your physical harm at worst
so um yeah i mean has it crossed my mind
sure
um is it possible that there'll be some
sort of you know deep ai smear campaign
yeah of course in fact i think that's
gonna it's gonna hit not just
you know truth tellers people who speak
up and and tell the american people
what's really going on but i think
you're also going to see different
politicians be hit by that that warning
has been out for a number of years so i
i absolutely think that it's possible
maybe not on an official basis but
former officers who might not like me uh
could decide to do you know little
shenanigans you know
sure but my bo my bottom line to anyone
who's worrying about that is if we live
in fear we will be ruled by it
so i'm not going to live in fear i know
who i am i know i'm a good man i'm not a
perfect man and if it is you know such
that i end up getting hit or smeared by
something then by god so be it then
somebody else is going to pick up the
flag and they're going to grab that
thing and they're going to keep running
forward because this place is
exceptional this country is exceptional
it's worth fighting for it is imperfect
but it's our job to make it better and
i'm not going to be ruled by fear and i
don't think people like you are either
and what's awesome about people like you
with your voice people who are putting
out incredible books like you are you're
telling people don't live in fear either
find alternatives keep pushing and do
not stop because this place is worth
saving
that should be the end of the show but
we still got some more time but that was
that was a beautiful opus to uh to end
this thing on now you've put a lot of
pressure on yourself to end this thing
to end this thing properly
somebody give me a lincoln speech i
don't know
um
since we we're sort of bouncing around
with a whole bunch of stuff here so
let's just keep going then when it comes
to the the way
the intelligence community deals with
media
and with big tech
um
what should we be thinking about
worrying about so you know if we just
back up to the again to the biden laptop
it wasn't just the 51
cia and intelligence officials it was
also that twitter got in on it so it's
like why has nobody said to twitter hey
who who decided that did you guys have a
meeting is there an email record of that
maybe a calendar invite
yeah
so you know if is the ultimate question
how the heck do we get a uh a lasso on
big tech and make sure that they're
sticking to you know what they should be
which is you know the provider of
opportunities to share speech versus
sensors
there are very smart people working on
this issue you are one with locals and
and other great solutions and i think
that's what you do you start building
your own infrastructure
to reach people and that's going to take
time that's going to take a lot of
effort and a lot of money i think we're
starting to see people who
might not necessarily be an ideological
partner in some ways but guys like elon
musk who are stepping up to the plate
and saying hey here are my resources not
because i love you know conservatives or
you know liberals but
damn it there should be a platform for
people to speak truth or their version
of it and the answer to crazy talk is
more sane talk
and that's always been the actual
liberal position you've talked about
this that's the classic liberal position
that has been abandoned by the left um
and they've embraced tyranny and
censorship you know so i think that it
is
more of us recognizing what's happening
uh and more people with influence people
like you people with money like elon
musk finding market solutions to this
problem and then it's about next fall
god willing conservatives take over
from no matter if you agree or disagree
on some of the you know other
party platform positions this has to be
a central one
and so when you go to vote you make it
very clear to the person you're voting
for in whatever way you do that look i
might not otherwise have voted for you
but this is an important issue to me the
censorship stuff this it's really about
our constitutional rights they're under
assault fix it and maybe i'll vote for
you again i don't know but you deserve
one shot to get this right because it's
an existential problem and it's
important to me
you mean you don't necessarily deserve
60 years in the senate like some of
these people or in the house or whatever
they're doing not the senators but the
people in the house that are there
forever and nancy pelosi's been there 87
years something like that it's just it
never ends
can you talk a little bit about
generally how in politics
secrets remain secrets
so or things like for example things
that we can see that we all can kind of
see with our own eyes that somehow just
never get discussed so
the biden cognitive stuff it's obvious
everyone knows it every single person
that you mentioned to
you talk about it privately everyone
will admit something is not right there
but no one's allowed to talk about it on
mainstream it's never brought up
meanwhile if trump was slurring every
one of his words and making up stories
and having these
blips that just go completely awry
we would have 25th amended amendment him
you know seven times ago so so
what do we do how does that happen i
guess is the question well look i think
that what do we do we have some ideas i
just said one of the 25th amendment
look i think if you look back in
american history there have been times
when the media has stepped in to hide uh
a deficiency of a leader so i'm thinking
of roosevelt and some of his you know
physical challenges being in a
wheelchair and so forth so it's not
unprecedented the issue is
why are we hiding that is to say why is
the press hiding this thing that might
otherwise be bad or perceived as bad in
the world
you know for
roosevelt it was about you know would
people view him as weak if he couldn't
stand up on his own two feet right and
but otherwise his mind his
decision-making process is the
the ability to surround himself with
smart people and make good decisions for
the country that was never in doubt so
it was more of a
this is a private matter that made him
sort of look
less manly perhaps or it was wrong of
course he was just as manly as he was
ever in each wheelchair otherwise but at
the time that was kind of the logic it
was a bit more of a genteel approach to
a personal problem right
but that's not the case anymore the
press is basically serving as the
mouthpiece for different politicians
right so it's i don't want this
embarrassing thing about their
infidelity or their cognitive impairment
or the fact that they've taken on you
know whatever degree of corruption right
their insider trading with stocks et
cetera so now the press knows those
things and if the person who's created
the the engaged in the sin for lack of a
better word
i'm gonna hide it because they're on my
team
right so the press has become part of a
team
and when you have that and the data by
the way supports that we we know that
for instance that the press gives
overwhelmingly to democrats anywhere
depending on the poll you look at 83 85
percent to 95 98 percent
no matter what you look it's
overwhelming so they've chosen a team
and they're hiding the bad stuff that
their team engages in that's what's
different as compared to what's happened
historically so how do you change that
matt you just keep calling it out and
and the american people see it and
what's happening is you they're starting
to gravitate to voices that they think
are more reasonable so mainstream media
is being challenged by you know smaller
voices but that's great it's a
marketplace of ideas it allows really
really smart people yourself and others
to stand up and say hey look
listen here's my own bias i'm going to
admit it unlike some of the people in in
mainstream media i'm going to tell you
what my biases are and where i've come
from as brian is a dem former democrat
now republican conservative like you
know that on the table i'm not hiding
any of that so let me present you the
material i'm going to offer you my
reflection and then you can decide what
to do with it or add it to other voices
i think that's what's going to just
naturally happen and is already
happening
are there any countries or security
services information services that are
doing it significantly better like if we
get the right people in
is there anyone we can look at that is
doing it right and we could be like hey
borrow the manual that they have over
there
now i'm i'm sorry to say that this issue
of the politization of media is
widespread it's across the country and
it's been bad in in lots of places for a
long time and i don't think anybody's
got it right anybody's doing it well um
unfortunately so that means that we have
to come up with the set of solutions and
i think we're going to try different
things here and something's going to
work and some things won't and that's
all right but i think at the end of the
day
my hope
and you hate to base a plan on this is
that there are going to be enough people
in journalism and the owners on the
editors who are like look we're losing
audience share and they're going to
other places and and listening to other
people
uh because we are such partisan folks
and so it's we are incentivized
advertisers like us because we've
started to gravitate back to just
wonkite like news right
um i would love to think that that's
possible i don't know that it's going to
happen here because most of us click or
are attracted to media outlets and
personalities who reaffirm our own
biases so i don't know what's going to
break that fever um but what about what
about on the intelligence side i'm with
you on the media side but
are there any countries
here this hemisphere the other
hemisphere maybe on another planet is
someone doing this somewhat okay
so i'll tell you i think that a lot of
that uh is pretty close hold so i don't
know the extent to which it's being
rooted out what i do know is that in
other countries uh if they find that
there is no rule you know publicizing
that
uh they end up just
disappearing people right they sort of
clean house in that sense so
unfortunately that there is no good path
but again i would go back to the fact
what we did in the 1970s when the cia
got so out of whack we dealt with it
publicly and then we had reforms and so
we did it before and i think we can do
it again with thoughtful people who
understand that the problem is real
that's the actual issue right now you
have people in congress who don't think
the issue is real that we don't have a
politicized intelligence community or a
politicized law enforcement community
some of them believe that privately but
they're not willing to do anything about
it publicly because the fbi or the cia
has been on their side right you
remember that the democratic congressman
who was going to give a job to the
disgrace you know fbi uh official who'd
done good things for the democrats like
that's the kind of stuff that you have
to remove those people putting good
people in your house and your senate who
are focused on the country and then you
have these panels these investigations
you come up with reforms and you get it
done we've done it before we can do it
again
usually when they screw up or lie to
congress they just get a job on cnn
right
that's generally how it works brian i
suspect a political future for you i
don't know that you suspect one
and i thought you were going to make
that very face but i i suspect one
you know well okay look that's very kind
seriously i mean i go back to this idea
of like it's it's our republic if we can
keep it so as as much as i make that
grimace faces everyone does like we have
to all figure out ways to get involved
right so if that's running for your
local city council or being part of your
school board if it's a county
commissioner at some level like it
doesn't have to be you know the top of
the the poll you know in terms of being
president or senator or something if
that's your passion and you've got the
money great
but just we all have to get involved so
my scrunchy face uh
getting involved
uh is is on the national level man it's
just
i think we all know what happens when
people run for office stuff gets yanked
out of uh your your past the completely
misrepresented um or you know you're
imperfect right and so nobody wants to
face that i don't have a lot of that so
that's not what anchors me it's just the
idea of
man just being a public person always
under the microscope so that's why i'm
doing a podcast so
that doesn't make any sense i love my
argument i just undermined it it's great
well former county commissioner brian
dean wright i appreciate you doing the
show
and uh look forward to seeing you soon
thanks man if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell